i'm here with fabiano caruana who just
drew magnus carlsen can you tell us a
little bit about the opening were you
expecting this how did it ranked in your
expectations no I didn't really expect
this it it's a little bit better for
white but it's I think it's pretty
harmless and I mean I probably caused
more difficulties for myself than I
needed to going for this Queen B 6 & a 6
although it's probably objectively drove
the entire time so you think you could
have just played something solid like
Queen d6 instead yeah i mean i'll have
to suffer a bit but it's going to be a
draw that it's you went for the more
tactical route no I wanted to force
things but I kind of underestimated the
strength of the deep own so when
somebody play something that's not
expected that you think is harmless are
you happy because it's harmless or
disappointed because you're not is like
sharp on the lines I did promise someone
I would win today so there were no
chances for that after about ten moves
oh yeah but I can't say I was
disappointed or anything because I mean
you know I could also be cause serious
problems in opening and this was was a
relatively um I mean a relatively simple
way to make a draw so you promise to win
with black yeah maybe wasn't the wisest
promise to make what are you gonna do
tomorrow do you have any promises for us
tomorrow uh no no promises we'll see how
it goes all right Thank You favi on Oak
arowana he's got two dogs now in the
London chess classic and as always a
little bit of st. Louis here